[Applaudissements]
madame la première ministre depuis
presque dix jours de deux gigantesques
feu ravage la gironde plus de 20 mille
hectares on l'a dit de végétation ont
été brûlés demi sapeurs pompiers sont
mobilisés appuyés par les canadair deux
avions dash je veux tout d'abord rendre
hommage à ces soldats du feu ainsi
qu'aux maires des communes sont
concernées la gironde est le département
de la france où il a le plus de départs
de feux éteints en général actuellement
la chaleur caniculaire l'hygrométrie
basse et les vents génère des feux
dynamique d'une ampleur exceptionnelle
ces phénomènes nous les reverrons
régulièrement madame la première
ministre l'état doit rapidement adapté
son dispositif de lutte contre les
incendies aux évolutions climatiques
désormais c'est l'ensemble de la france
qui est concerné 31 % du territoire
métropolitain est concerné et moisé or
les moyens de l'état dédiés au
fonctionnement d'esdi sont insuffisants
ne correspondent plus à la réalité
l'assiette sur laquelle se fixe le
financement des secours n'a pas évolué
depuis vingt ans alors que parallèlement
la gironde et les landes ont gagné
environ quatre cent mille habitants
d'autre part les moyens aériens ont fait
défaut au début d'incendié en
particulier à landiras le renforcement
de la force aérienne nationale de la
sécurité civile est urgent afin qu'elles
puissent agir dès le départ du feu outre
leur nombre la localisation des
bombardiers d'eau à proximité est
primordiale face à la rupture majeure
que constitue le changement climatique
la prévention est vital
l'augmentation des départs de feux
nécessitant un besoin constant en
investissement à la charge des
forestiers également pour maintenir un
bon niveau de prévention ainsi les
sylviculteurs du sud ouest sont les
seuls à payer une taxe en france pour
organiser la défense des forêts contre
les incendies
cette taxe dès fci permet entre autres
de financer par feu et réserves d'eau la
situation nous impose d'agir rapidement
pour garantir l'avenir de nos forêts
madame la première ministre souhaiterait
savoir concrètement quels moyens quels
dispositifs le gouvernement envisage de
mettre en oeuvre pour lutter contre les
incendies